so tomorrow I know you're not the
biggest fan of Warhammer yeah I know you
for nerds in it is for nerds and I am
the biggest nerd around but I couldn't
you you appreciate when a game does
something cool yeah I got to play total
war Warhammer mortal Empires
yesterday yes oh very cool that what is
more empires because talwar Warhammer 2
just came out right yeah so that's
really choirs is but when they announced
the the trilogy taht was they said
eventually they're gonna combine all the
maps and all the factions this is the
first out step of that so it combines
everything from game one with everything
from game two and allows you to combine
them both and if you own both the games
ready and it's free right I was playing
yesterday and it's the biggest total war
map I believe they've ever made yeah
from what I've seen there's a lot of
like factions and all these nitty-gritty
things that people love in the total
Warhammer games it's all together it
seems quite overwhelming how much of
that stuff is there it's it's got 117
starting factions says they're like
offshoots than are the main ones like
nearly 300 settlements nearly 300 Maps
you can actually battle on 35 of the
legendary Lords all the magical spells
and it's it's it's just fascinating to
see them all come together because when
you start the first game you had four
and then more and more came in with DLC
but now they've brought all of them it's
it was a little overwhelming when I
started to play the way that they've
like seen it end is that they've been
automatically running campaigns they are
playing overnight and just just watching
the end results right so I started I
played as the Empire which is the the
faction for much everyone started with
with the first house I just wanted to
see how different it was I kind of felt
like I was gonna be playing the same
faction again for the same campaign
again but because of the new way it's
it's built the factions are very
different so you could play one faction
on their solo campaign they'll play
completely differently in the immortal
empires campaign literally just because
there's so much more of it there's way
more like possible interactions and
variables that can change because all
the battles are also happening between
the AI on the other side of the world
you're not even seeing if you play it
one day the Lizardman could emerge
victorious and invade you another day it
could be completely different faction
because there's also so many fashions
it's like it's balanced on like hundreds
of knife edges all at once that make
sense yeah like one tiny Battle of the
star could mean they blow up out of
control and become like like a worldwide
superpower and towards the end of the
game and just come and just come and
crush you right and in terms of like
obviously this is an isolated game mode
I presume right because you know told
war Warhammer - has a story
yeah but factoring all those factors
into a properly crafted story is
probably impossible yeah this is this is
just sandbox right a lot of the moments
that came out of it from when I was
playing is it's those you know I we used
the term like water cooler moments just
call things that happen that might not
happen 20 wells there was a lot of that
like there was a moment where I crafted
a battle that was the Empire the humans
with dwarves and the elves it was like I
felt like I was defending middle-earth
or something which is it's it's just a
battle that you've never seen before and
we were against chaos Skaven and green
skins and it's really the coolest battle
i've seen in in any total war game right
so in that respect it seems kind of like
a civilization game in terms of how you
play it like it's one of those things
where you fire it up and it's it's just
about kind of spending a whole bunch of
time has been really long campaign and
like having those war cooler moments
playing this for hundreds of hours I
played a save like it was so long they
were like okay you can you can try it at
first but we've given you late-game
saves because you couldn't you're gonna
be here for weeks of those I think I
loaded to say that was a hundred and
forty something turns in wasn't quite
loud turns and it was the guy owned like
an eighth of the map so given that
there's so many factions now there's got
to be like really weird gameplay
emerging game play things that are
happening that kind of enabled those
water cooler moments that weren't
possible in either the first game or the
second game in isolation right well I
met actually that we did a little Q&A
with the devs and I mentioned that at
one point there was it was my army there
was elves allied with dwarven army which
obviously wasn't possible before and
they were fighting and I made both the
Lords from both armies cast a similar
skill on this on the same area of units
like a massive combat buff from the
elves and then a massive combat buff
from the dwarves which ended up stacking
and making that my units of elves are
basically invincible and trashed like
for other units all by themselves and as
lights that does that cause an issue for
balance and they were like no because
that's that scenario has probably
actually only happened to you right
because it's such a slim chance of it
happening right that it was it doesn't
make it it's not game breaking runs very
hard to make that happen organically not
organically sorry like make it happen on
purpose it's it is the kind of thing
that just happens by accident right and
because there's all these new elements
in play and they've all kind of brought
them together it's it's that emerging
gameplay starts that it's that kind of
thing that Talwar fans have been wanting
for a long time and a lot of people just
want to want this huge map that they can
paint red and if that's your objective
if you if you're the kind of player like
me who just wants to get a campaign map
and I was like my end objective is for
every settlement to be under my control
right that's something you can do and
this might sound like a stupid question
but I imagine it might it may have a
bearing on it like how does this impact
your kind of ability to run it depending
on your your computer is it do you know
if it's more taxing than the original
two games there are moments where like
whenever you've seen that walk yeah yeah
when you end a turn it goes to this
cycle of all the factions that takes
ages now yeah okay because there's so
many that the game has to run through
and when when I did have a battle that
was 3v3
there was a lot of units on the board
right and then it does kind of chug a
little bit but if you do want like
massive like six stack battles it's
probably gonna tax your PC yes so it's
probably worth bearing in mind that you
might require decent PC if you want to
try and have these huge huge open ended
yeah but then like that that's always
been the way to total war like if you if
you go into custom battles and create a
massive fight it'll be don't be a
warning being like just FYI framerate
gonna chug a little bit here yeah that's
fair it seems like the kind of game
that's gonna be really interesting to
watch long twitch plays of or like I
feel serious when I was playing through
I was thinking I would really love to
see just like time lapses of
the world map most how little things
change and how you can change one
variable and then it just drastically so
no ball out of control and I mean this
is this is for the two games and they're
doing this again with will have a three
right so at the minute we've got tote
wall what have a one and all its DLCs
till war Warhammer - mmm and it will
include all of the DLCs right and
eventually it'll be total war Warhammer
one two and three and all that DLCs so
probably nearly two hundred starring
functions and they've said before we're
not we're not revealing something inside
a knowledge they've said before that
there's three games cuz it's a yeah you
know multi-part the chapter based and
eventually they'll they'll all merge
together they have to kind of chop and
change some of the maps but eventually
it's gonna be I just I can't imagine me
finishing a campaign because it will
literally take until I'm old and gray
and it'll probably destroy whatever
computer you've got all running I can't
wait to try that I'll give it a shot
yeah it sounds pretty interesting I mean
I played a bit of each game just to be
informed on them and they they are
complex and obviously rewarding for a
lot of people who can dig into those so
for those people the idea of having even
more than ever and having it all kind of
work symbiotically with each other it
sounds super exciting and if you if
you've been like a total war war fan and
like a Warhammer fan you've suddenly
starting to get like the battles that
you've always wanted which for me being
the Warhammer fan is just setting my new
meter off the off the scale I'm loving
it yeah well I've reached my maximum for
nerd all right Warhammer exposure dragon
I drag this up please swag you back in
when to a Warhammer 3 alright well for
that's that small empires if you're a
fan of the Total War series make sure
you check it out its new it's different
and I think you really look really
really enjoy it yeah we've got a review
for the last game on the site at
Gamescom Warhammer 2 and it was received
very well so if you want to learn more
about that check it out yeah right
thanks for joining me Tom I'm sorry to
hear about no stuff it's fight night I
secretly love it ever every nerd list
name glad you enjoyed us